As you can tell from the title of this video,
I’m going ask a question, not a confusing question,
a simple question, and no Muslim
on the planet, not the least, not the greatest,
will be able to answer it.
In fact, I’m so confident that no Muslim will be
able to answer my easy, straightforward question
that I hereby vow that I will record
myself bowing down and reciting the Shahada
if a single Muslim can answer it.
Once our Muslim friends realize why they can’t
answer my simple question,
they’re on their way out of Islam.
If you’ve had a discussion with a Muslim,
you’ve probably heard the Muslim ask,
“Where did Jesus say, ‘I am God, worship
me,’ in those words?”
Muslims were trained by Zakir Naik and Ahmed Deedat to ask this question.
More recently, Zakir Naik and Co. have been
training Muslims to say,
“Show me one unequivocal statement where
Jesus Christ (peace be upon him) says,
‘I am God,’ or ‘Worship me.’”
“Show me one unequivocal statement where
Jesus Christ (peace be upon him) says,
‘I am God,’ or ‘Worship me.’”
Notice, Zakir Naik and Co. demand that the
statement be unequivocal, meaning unambiguous,
not open to interpretation, leaving no room
for doubt.
They demand an unequivocal statement because
they know that no matter what Jesus said,
they can always reinterpret it.
In the Quran, Allah calls himself “the First
and the Last.”
In the New Testament, Jesus calls himself
“the First and the Last.”
In the Quran, Allah says that he’s the one
who will judge the world.
In the New Testament, Jesus says that he’s
the one who will judge the world.
In the Quran, Allah says that he’s the one
who will raise the dead at the resurrection.
In the New Testament, Jesus says that he’s
the one who will raise the dead at the resurrection.
Over and over again, Jesus makes claims that,
even according to the Quran,
only God can truly make.
What do Muslims conclude from all of this?
They conclude that Jesus was only claiming
to be a prophet.
The central and sole miracle of Islam is the
miracle of reinterpretation.
But Muslims don’t just reinterpret
the words of Jesus.
They reinterpret the words of their own god
and their own prophet.
What does Allah mean when he orders his followers
to “fight those who do not believe in Allah”?
He clearly means that Muslims are only allowed
to fight in self-defense.
Miracle of reinterpretation.
What does Allah mean when he says that Muslim
men can beat their wives into submission?
He clearly means that Muslim men are only
allowed to tap their wives gently with a toothbrush.
Miracle of reinterpretation.
What does Muhammad mean when he says, “If
anyone leaves his Islamic religion, kill him”?
He clearly means that if anyone wants to leave
Islam, he’s free to go.
Miracle of reinterpretation.
And we see this method on full display when
we go deeper into a specific topic.
Take the Quran’s interesting claims about
the Gospel.
What does Allah mean in Surah 3, verses 3
to 4, when he says that he revealed the Gospel
as a guidance for mankind?
Well, Allah means that even though he revealed
the Gospel, it was corrupted by the Apostle
Paul and by Christians at the Council of Nicea,
and it ended up not guiding mankind.
Then what does Allah mean when he says, in
Surah 7, verse 157, that Christians still
had the Gospel in the seventh century, long
after the Apostle Paul and the Council of Nicea?
Oh, he only means that some truths still remained
in the corrupt Gospel.
Then what does Allah mean in Surah 18, verse
27, and Surah 6, verse 115 that no one
can changes his words?
That just means that no one can change Allah’s
plans.
But the context of both verses is that you
should read the Book that he has revealed,
because no one can change his words.
Well, then he clearly means that no one can
change his words in the Quran,
even though they can change his words in other books.
Then why didn’t he say that?
Why did he say that no one can change his
words, when he really meant that people can
change his words in other books but not in
the Quran?
Oh, you know, we have to interpret these things.
Miracle of reinterpretation!
So why does Allah command Christians, in Surah
5, verse 47 of the Quran, to judge by the Gospel,
and why does he tell Christians that if they don’t judge by the Gospel,
they’re in rebellion against him?
Oh, that’s easy.
When Allah commands Christians to judge by
the Gospel, he means that Christians should
read the Quran, then go to the Gospel and
find the parts that agree with the Quran,
and then judge by those, but throw the rest
out.
Uh-huh.
Why does Allah say, in Surah 5, verse 68 of
the Quran, that Christians have no ground
to stand upon unless they stand upon
the Torah, the Gospel,
and all the revelation that has come to them?
Yeah, well, Allah obviously means that the
Quran is the only preserved revelation and
that the Gospel has been corrupted.
Miracle of reinterpretation!
That’s how conversations go when we ask
Muslims what the Quran says about the Gospel.
They reinterpret everything Allah says so
that they can bring it in line with what they’ve
been told by their leaders.
Muslim leaders have Allah on a leash, like
a dog, with a muzzle, and Allah is only allowed
to speak when they say, “Speak!”
But recall the Muslim methodology.
When we claim that the Bible teaches something,
they demand an unequivocal statement.
The statement must be unequivocal, unambiguous,
not open to interpretation,
leaving no room for doubt.
Why? Because Muslim leaders are professional reinterpreters.
They do it with the words of their own god,
their own book, their own prophet.
Why wouldn’t they do the same with our God,
our Book, our Lord?
But now that Muslims have presented their
standard—an unequivocal statement—
it would be a shame if we didn’t apply that
same standard to them.
It would be a shame if we didn’t demand
consistency.
So let’s demand consistency.
Let’s demand unequivocal statements.
We’ll start with an easy one.
Muslims, where does Allah declare, unequivocally,
in the Quran, that the text of the Gospel
has been corrupted?
Give us one unequivocal statement from Allah
in the Quran saying that the text of the Injil,
the Gospel, has been corrupted.
Just one.
If you can give us one unequivocal statement
from Allah in the Quran,
saying that the text of the Gospel has been corrupted, again,
I will record myself bowing down and
reciting the Shahada.
Now, I know that you Muslims who watch my
videos don’t read your own sources,
let alone our sources.
So all you’re about to do is Google “Where does the Quran say that the Gospel has been corrupted?”
And you’re going to get some verses.
But before you post those verses in the comments
section, try reading them.
Ask yourselves, “Where does this verse
say it’s referring to the Gospel?
Where does this verse say it’s about the
corruption of the text,
not about people misinterpreting the text
or misrepresenting the text?”
Once you’ve put together your best and clearest
verses, share them in the comments section
and see what people have to say about them.
This Friday, I’ll go live on my channel
with Sam Shamoun,
and you can give us the best of the best live.
We’ll discuss the verses one by one, and
if you’re able to give us a single, unequivocal
statement where Allah in the Quran says that
the text of the Gospel has been corrupted,
I will conclude the livestream by bowing down
and reciting the Shahada.
Doesn’t get more exciting than that!
See you all Friday.